[Música]
me gustaría empezar con un pensamiento
general que es que las personas pasamos
gran parte de nuestra vida educando a
los a veces cuando pensamos en educación
pensamos directamente en la escuela y
eso es lógico porque en la escuela
pasamos gran parte de nuestra vida desde
las edades más tempranas
hasta que somos adultos
en la escuela aprendemos muchas cosas en
la escuela aprendemos conceptos
aprendemos cuestiones de distintas
disciplinas que son muy útiles en la
escuela a veces encontramos en nuestra
vocación
pero la escuela no es el único espacio
en donde nos educamos
citando a elisabeth cabal ya ella nos
invita a diferenciar entre educación y
escolarización la escuela forma parte de
la educación formal pero también hay
otros espacios donde todo el tiempo
estamos aprendiendo fuera del aula y eso
nos lleva al concepto de educación no
formal ya la educación no formal es la
que adquirimos por medio de
interacciones con otras personas de
pláticas con nuestras familias con
nuestras amistades de medios de
comunicación porque también nos educamos
y aprendemos en los medios de
comunicación o si pensamos ya en el
siglo 21 pues las redes sociales son un
arma muy poderosa en cuestiones de
aprendizaje y de educación entonces la
educación no formal tiene un peso bien
importante y hay que visibilizar lo por
ejemplo si pensamos en algún pensamiento
o en alguna postura que tengamos sobre
el tema que sea es altamente probable
que eso lo hayamos refrendado en
conversaciones en lecturas en vídeos por
este medio no formal en pláticas con
personas en los que confiamos y creo que
allí podemos encontrar algo bien valioso
y es el hecho de que hay grandes
maestros y maestras en el aula
obviamente pero también fuera del aula
entonces creo que el aceptar que la
educación formal y la educación no
formal se complementan todo el tiempo y
dialogar nos lleva también a darnos
cuenta de que existe una libertad muy
valiosa en el proceso educativo de cada
persona y eso está bien está bien que
seamos libres para aprender o
seleccionar la información a la que
estamos expuestos
por lo mismo yo creo que es muy
importante que desarrollamos dos
cuestiones la primera es el pensamiento
crítico porque más ahora que tenemos
tanta información tenemos que saber
discernir entre lo que es real y lo que
no
o lo que es tendencioso para tomar
buenas decisiones y la segunda cuestión
que tenemos que desarrollar es la ética
desde una perspectiva universal
porque a la hora de aprender y
transmitir información
tenemos que pensar siempre en otras
personas no estamos solos entonces el
pensamiento crítico y la ética
son partes fundamentales del proceso
educativo que tenemos tanto en la
escuela como fuera de la escuela hay un
autor mexicano que se llama abel pérez
rojas que acuña junto con otras personas
el término de educación permanente y es
que todo el tiempo estamos aprendiendo
porque estamos expuestos a información a
opiniones y porque el mundo cambia y nos
tenemos que adaptar y yo creo que la
academia también tiene que renovarse y
refrescarse y ser consciente de esto
entonces me gustaría expresar otra vez
una dicotomía que es muy interesante y
que nos puede ayudar a entender qué
habilidades tenemos que desarrollar
tanto dentro como fuera de la escuela
en la escuela casi siempre nos enfocamos
en habilidades duras las habilidades
duras son todos los aprendizajes
técnicos que adquirimos los aprendizajes
útiles si por ejemplo
y saber manejar o el saber operar una
máquina u operar a una persona o
resolver un problema matemático o un
problema social
todo esto tiene que ver con aprendizajes
metódicos que adquirimos de manera
formal pero hay otro tipo de habilidades
que son igual de relevantes que son las
habilidades blandas las habilidades
blandas tienen que ver con la
inteligencia emocional con la empatía
con la adaptabilidad
y con muchas cuestiones que en ocasiones
se ignoran desde una perspectiva formal
pero que son igual de importantes
hace poco link being publicaba que en
grandes empresas del mundo además de la
experiencia laboral o además de los
aprendizajes técnicos se fijan mucho en
que las personas puedan desarrollar este
tipo de habilidades interpersonales
porque al final a la hora de
desarrollarnos en el mundo laboral
tenemos que tener esa capacidad de
negociar de comprender otros puntos de
vista de organizarnos con otras personas
de hecho no solo en el mundo laboral
necesitamos estas habilidades también en
nuestra vida cotidiana si pensamos en
cualquier conflicto puede ser un
conflicto micro que tengamos de manera
personal de nuestro ámbito académico e
laboral o puede ser un conflicto macro
algo que nos afecte a todas las personas
normalmente la resolución de esos
conflictos tiene que ir precisamente por
la vía de las habilidades blandas rara
vez
un conflicto no se soluciona porque no
sepamos desde un punto de vista técnico
cómo solucionarlo
casi siempre es porque nos atoramos en
los procesos de diálogo con los procesos
de adaptabilidad oa la hora de
interactuar y tomar decisiones
entonces me gustaría llevar esto otra
vez al terreno educativo
porque vemos a la educación como un
proceso que tiene un fin y casi siempre
ese fin parece ser
económico o al menos aspiracional
estudiamos mucho tiempo porque queremos
formarnos con habilidades duras para
encontrar un empleo y poder superarlos
y me gustaría que se acudiéramos un
poquito esta idea este paradigma porque
la verdad es que la educación si es un
proceso pero la educación no tiene un
fin porque la educación nunca finaliza y
la educación tampoco tiene un objetivo
meramente económico la educación tienen
muchos objetivos que todo el tiempo se
están reconfigurando volviendo al punto
de las habilidades blandas en la
resolución de conflictos creo que la
buena noticia es que casi cualquier
conflicto se puede solucionar pero
tenemos que recurrir a la educación
porque los procesos educativos formales
y no formales son los que nos pueden
ayudar a prevenir incluso la aparición
de esos conflictos
creo para concluir que si desde la
academia y fuera de la academia vemos a
la educación como algo muy integral un
proceso en el cual siempre están
dialogando cuestiones duras y blandas de
educación formal y no formal y sobre
todo un proceso en el que en el centro
tiene que estar la persona
podemos encontrar ciertas pistas de
hacia dónde tiene que ir la educación en
el siglo 21
a una educación probablemente en la cual
se favorezca el sentido de la ética en
la cual también se forjen las bases del
pensamiento crítico de manera personal y
una educación que nos ayude a resolver
conflictos de la mano de otras personas
y eso nos va a ayudar mucho en el
cambiar esta perspectiva desde un punto
de vista más integral nos puede ayudar
repito no solo en los procesos formales
sino también en nuestra vida cotidiana